welcome to Ted connects this is a new
series of live conversations trying to
make sense of this weird moment that
we're in its coronavirus everyone's
suddenly changing how they live their
lives it's so jolting it's so startling
we're all trying to make sense of it and
it ain't easy that much we know that
we're trying to make sense of this
together in the way the only way that we
know how which is by having wise humans
coming on talking to each other
listening to each other trying to learn
from each other we are apart but we can
use this moment to build community
together and that's what we're trying to
do so this is being produced by a
virtual Ted team scattered around New
York currently one of the epicenters
relieve this pandemic so it's definitely
a scary time for people here I'd like to
welcome to join me my co-host here
Whitney Pennington Rogers she's our
current affairs curative we're gonna be
looking a little bit at China's response
today when news surfaced about a strange
viral outbreak in Wuhan China at the
very last days of 2019 I think a lot of
people were confused about what was
going on there and in the months that
followed we learned more about the
disease that's now known as open 19
we watched the situation in China
quickly worsen and in the most recent
weeks dramatically improve and I think
as all of us around the world grapple
with how we can contain and control the
spread of cope at 19 there are a lot of
lessons we can learn from what China
experienced and how they responded so
we're really thrilled to be joined today
by the CEO of the South China Morning
Post Gary Lu who's here to share his
perspective and insights so welcome Gary
thanks for having me hey there Gary
thanks for being with us and I think
before we dive into things I'd love to
hear about just how things have been for
you personally and your loved ones those
close to you how have you been
experiencing this it's
that's complicated so we're here in Hong
Kong I'm working from home like much of
Hong Kong I'm actually actually self
quarantined in our apartment here in
Hong Kong because there was a confirmed
case in our workplace so over the course
of the last week plus and likely for at
least another week plus the entire
organization has been distributed and
working from home you know when Hong
Kong got its first confirmed case I was
actually back in the United States with
my wife we were taking a small break in
in the Rockies and we came back to Hong
Kong pretty soon after that to make sure
it's have to make sure we got back into
Hong Kong before the airport shut and at
that point it was all of our family in
the United States and friends texting us
and worrying about how things were in
Hong Kong as the situation in China
started escalating and people were
sending us or trying to send us supplies
masks and sanitized and stuff like that
and now it's the opposite New York is at
home New York City is at home so we
certainly empathize with what you guys
are dealing with right now and going
through in the city and and we are
seeing our friends in our family back
home in New York in California and
checking in on them trying to send
equipment and materials back to them so
that the script has flipped actually
pretty fast over just the last couple of
weeks
and you know I think that's actually a
really interesting place to start and
probably a question that a lot of people
who aren't in China have you know I
think from the outside looking in it
seems as if what's happened in China is
kind of miraculous that to go from you
know you have a country with more than a
billion people there to go from as many
as 80,000 cases to nearly ten nearly
zero new cases now you know what what
can you tell us about how this happened
to help us understand the current
situation and just really how China
ended up there yeah a lot has happened
China's been dealing with this for
several months now several month head
start that's not a good thing but they
have they have gone through several
different phases I think we need before
I jump into it there couple of caveats
that are really important to make the
first one is that we are still parsing
what
been in China the the information system
as everyone knows is still relatively
closed and so a lot of the information
that that we're using to piece together
what happened in China is still not
fully complete and so with every passing
day every passing week there's more
information that allows us to retro
actively make sure that we get the
picture of what happened early on in
those early days at the end of 2019 get
get that picture right and there's still
a lot of lot that's happening today even
though I think the information sherry is
is much more open than it was early on
there's still a lot of stuff that we
need a parse and the second important
caveat here is that I think learning
sometimes suggests that everything China
did was was right and good and and
hopefully other countries can can can
take it and apply it but that's not a
hundred percent the case China of course
did a lot that was right and if we
walked through the timeline I think
he'll be pretty apparent the decisions
that they made that that kept the
coronavirus from really exploding across
the entire country and really limited to
one province and mostly one city but
there were also many many missteps and
those are things that I think the world
can also learn from most importantly
China should learn from because most of
these these what I think those of us who
are professional observers would call
missteps are because there are systemic
issues with the country because of
governance lack of free information flow
stuff like that so those are the initial
caveat but I think the timing of how
China progressed from first case to now
has been has been fascinating yeah I
mean and so we know now that and in whom
a province
they've lift lifted officially lifted
the two-month lockdown and and are you
getting the sense do you feel like this
is the right decision to make at this
moment I I don't think I'm the right
person to say whether or not is the
right decision but it certainly this is
this has been progression of decisions
and I think that they've been sitting on
decision for quite some time
Wuhan itself which was the where the the
pandemic started I was the first
epicenter and the major epicenter
Wuhan is opening up and on April 8th
that's right now the schedule
and this is really what we're in now is
the third of three phases from the first
discovery of the virus and Wuhan now
April 8 will be about 11 weeks after
Wuhan the city got completely shut down
and who Bay Province got shut down
and so for those who are in a shelter at
home kind of situations right now in the
United States and wondering how long
this is going to take in in ohan they've
been they've been locked down for 11
weeks and only now has the Chinese
government decided they're ready to
start letting people move freely around
and to your point earlier about some of
aqua missteps in terms of recording I
mean there's still reports now that we
might not be getting the an accurate
number of cases that we're seeing in
Wuhan or beyond that we're hearing some
people say there are no new cases other
people saying but there actually are
cases so are you do you feel like
there's there is accurate spread of
information about the current state of
the virus in China right now generally
yes with the caveat that it is based on
the Chinese government's definition and
this is one of the problems right now
that even the World Health Organization
is struggling with is that the
definition of what is a confirmed case
what is an infection is different from
country to country as an example in
China the folks that are tested positive
but are asymptomatic we understand now
that they are not included since for
every seventh they have not been
included in the official number so at
the very least on February 7th they
changed that definition and they're not
included in those official numbers and
that could be you know another 50% on
top of the numbers that we're seeing
today so there's what we've found our
reporters have gone their hands on some
classified government documents and
government data that suggests that a
third of total actual positive tests are
asymptomatic and therefore not included
in official numbers now this is now I
don't think that this is an example of
the Chinese government trying to hide
information this is a definitions issue
which countries have been debating and
people are doing it in different ways
but like I said there really have been
three very distinct phases we are in the
third phase that I would I
call recovery and rehabilitation
rehabilitation being the rehabilitation
of China's image but the first part was
discovery and a lot of denial and then
there was this two and a half month
period of response and containment and
that I think the response and
containment part is what is most
interesting to the rest of the world and
so maybe we can break some of that down
you know it's thinking about China's
response you know what what were some of
the specific things that you think China
did right both as a nation and
individuals in the country what were
some of the things that you saw that
that works really well okay so let me
walk through the timeline I want to try
and get these dates right because the
dates do matter I think for again for
context how many weeks it took from one
step to another let me actually back up
into that initial first phase that
discovery and denial phase the first
time we heard about the corona virus
this mysterious respiratory disease that
looks somewhat like SARS was on December
30th that was the day that there's a
doctor that is now his name is known all
over the world on for the unfortunate
reason that he ended ended up eventually
dying named Lee when Jung and Lee when
Lee on dr. Lee posts it to a private
WeChat group on December 30th these were
some of his old classmates from med
school and he said hey I'm in Wuhan I'm
at the hospital
there is a SARS like Vilnius SARS being
the epidemic from 2002 to 2003 there's a
SARS like illness that is spreading
through these hospitals in Wuhan a
private message somebody Ford it and it
went viral across the Chinese Internet
the very next that was the first time we
actually heard about something that was
going that what was going on in Wuhan
the very next day December 31st was the
first time that any Chinese officials
and on that day it happened to be the
actual provincial and the city officials
acknowledged that there were 27 people
at that moment in time who had been
diagnosed with this mysterious pneumonia
and they reported the cases to the World
Health Organization that was also the
day that dr. Li was reprimanded
officially reprimanded so that was
really the discovery that the the the
end of the discovery and denial phase
because what we know now
is that back to mid-december several
weeks before doctor Lee wrote his blog
post the authorities had already been
notified that as SARS like pneumonia was
showing up in wuhan hospitals and action
had already started down the chain of
authority they have now back dated at
least publicly back dated the first case
to December 1st but actually in their
confidential and classified government
documents that again our journalists
have seen that we've published a story
officially in classified documents they
backdated the first Cova 19 case all the
way back to November 17th that's the
earliest example that they can find
based on symptoms and based on
retroactive diagnosis for a Koba 19 case
so in effect there were several weeks
before the acknowledgment of the World
Health Organization that was something
that was going on and the first case
with symptoms was actually identified
about a month and a half before that
notice to what health organization then
the second phase which really started
let's say December 31st when the
acknowledgment happened was response and
then massive containment now this phase
to be clear still had some denial and a
good amount of censorship happening
within the country so on January 1st the
World Health Organization started
working with China on trying to identify
the virus and trying to figure out
course of action and wasn't until
several weeks later that Beijing the
central government for the first time
broke its silence and that was on
January 18th and actually they broke the
silence to deny that this was SARS in
effect to quote-unquote defy rumors that
were spreading around the Chinese
internet but there was a major date that
happened two days afterwards which was
January 20th because for the first time
a member of the the party and a senior
government official who is now one of
the central gentlemen that is actually
leading the the task force against Cova
nineteen's name is zona and son he's a
epidemiologist he was one of the central
figures during SARS 17 years ago on
January 20th he visited Wuhan and he
admitted for the first time that human
to human transmission was possible now
this is important because prior to that
officials who had spoken up had said
that human-to-human transmission was not
likely was not possible and you know
previous to that all of the cases what
the majority of the cases were tied to
this seafood and and wildlife the
marketplace that was in the city of
Oaxaca
but now on January 20th human to human
transmission it's possible it's
happening and so of course the course of
action not only in China for the course
of action all over the world started to
change and three days after that
Wuhan was locked out it was completely
you know this shocked the world that
they could lock down that many people so
quickly of course now India yesterday
announced that 1.3 billion people are
being locked down so we have another
frame of reference now and then the end
of this this little second phase I think
really came in March around March 10th
well actually on March 10th as you say
because Chinese President Xi Jinping
visited a new Han and these things in
Chinese politics because everything is
so walk choreographed matters a whole
lot the fact actually Jinping visited
Wuhan signaled that the Chinese
government believed the worst was over
the reality was that probably about 20
days before that the curve had already
been flattened so 20 days before that
probably around February 27 the 20th the
infection rate was around seventy five
thousand seventy six thousand and it's
effectively stayed within a couple of
thousands since then so on March 10th
seating things visit to Wuhan kind of
signaled the worst is over and then they
moved into the recovery and
rehabilitation phase okay I mean if I'm
hearing correctly thank you and thank
you for sharing all of that it sounds
like although that there was it was
there was a slow period of getting the
information out initially eventually
there was quick reaction from the
Chinese government to respond to this
lakh folks down and then and it seems
like that had a real impact on
flattening the curve in injury Aloha
yeah and absolutely and I'm it yes
please go ahead Gary know that the date
of January 23rd was not by coincidence
because the Chinese New Year holiday
started on Jan
24th the very next day and the thing is
with the Chinese New Year holiday is
that it is every single year it's the
largest human migration that happens on
amis about 400 million people travel
during about a 40 day period that would
have started on January 24th and that's
three billion trips that's just people
traveling all over the country 400
million people traveling now Wuhan is
one of the most important cities in
China or though before this I don't
think anyone and not a lot of people
around the world knew the city of Wuhan
but it's extremely important it is
considered the most important city in
the center of China for many different
reasons but one of the key reasons is
that it is one of the key transportation
hubs of the country so all of the major
train lines the high-speed train lines
and normal train lines the trade lines
they all kind of converge on one so you
can imagine if four hundred million
people start moving around for Chinese
New Year on January 24th a huge number
of them were gonna go through huh and of
course Wuhan itself is an 11 million
person City the surrounding cities all
added together who Bay province has
about 60 million people and they were
also life largely going to travel and so
if January 23rd they had not shut it
down and people had started traveling
the likelihood would have been that this
would have been really really hard
possibly likely impossible to contain
and even though they shut down before
the Chinese New Year holiday started we
now also know that at least 5 million
people actually left the surrounding
areas and traveled which is one of the
reasons why I did spread a little bit
across the country and then eventually
spread to other parts of the world and
I'd like to come back to that as well
just thinking about the 5 million people
who left and sort of where they landed
today and how that affected things but
before we do that I'm interested to even
talk with you a little bit more about
you know you mentioned this November
date as one of the earliest cases you
discovered that was recorded was in
November and that's something actually
that I hadn't heard before and I imagine
it might be news to a lot of people
hearing this and and so I'm curious when
you think about the missteps from
China's perspective in terms of what
China did you know there is as you
suppression of information is one thing
one major criticism of how China handled
this and hearing that maybe there was
knowledge of something as early as
November if that might have played a
role in and how we were able to control
and contain this a lot sooner I do want
to clarify I think from what we
understand officials were not notified
about this until mid-december it wasn't
so it was really took a couple of weeks
before between officials realizing that
there was a SARS like pneumonia going
around - when the first cases report the
World Health Organization it wasn't all
the way back to November 17th that was
retroactively Liebeck dated but that has
not been made public by the government
we published it because we've we've seen
the data that actually pack dates the
first case from a Mis set point of view
again it's a couple of weeks compared to
what happened in stars which was a long
time of locking down on information this
was much shorter the the period of time
and that the government wasn't in
complete shutdown mode but then after
that of course there was still continued
censorship on the internet especially
within the Great Firewall of China for
communications between Chinese citizens
and you know surprisingly to some I
think for a lot of China Watchers not so
surprisingly is that the government has
over the course of the central
government over the course of the last
several weeks really actually I should
say probably the last two months has
started to change their tone and to some
degree admit that they needed to be
better free flow of information they've
changed the official narrative of a
couple of different things including
this initial whistleblower dr. Lee who
unfortunately ended up passing away from
from the virus they they actually that
they now refer to him as a national hero
they have officially removed the
reprimand the Wuhan police have
apologized the dr. Lee's family and they
have actually been a couple of police
policemen have been punished in HoN for
the way that they handled the situation
so there has definitely been an internal
shift and there is a lot more sharing of
of data and information I can tell you
from Hong Kong's point of view with
the open sharing of information between
the authorities between Hong Kong and
male in China I think Hong Kong's
response would have been much more
different and I think Hong Kong would
have suffered because of that so that
much more open sharing of information
has benefited this city for sure and we
have Chris here who has a question I
think from the audience hey Gary
the online audience loving what you're
saying it's it's so interesting you're
giving us amazing new insights here just
in the current situation where mm much
of you know they've been these very few
reports of new cases how much does it
feel like life is getting back to normal
do people really believe that this this
problem has been successfully tackled
elsewhere do you think I think the
sentiment in mainland China is that yes
in China the problem has been tackled
and people are looking forward to going
back to normal life a lot of the other
major cities Shanghai Beijing are
starting to get back to work many of the
factories have now been reopened the
last set that I saw was that 90 percent
of the the businesses that had been shut
down are now reopened in China so
generally speaking life is getting back
to normal Wuhan and who Bay I really the
last places that are so shut down with
Wuhan being the city that has shut down
until April 8 Hong Kong is a little bit
different Hong Kong has actually gone
back into a second wave of social
isolation and distancing a bunch of
different companies included as well as
the Hong Kong government and the civil
service has now gone back to work from
home and it's because we are starting to
see a a second way but for us honestly
is the first time that we've had a spike
on of infections and it's because of
imported cases it's because a lot of
Hong Kong residents who left Hong Kong
prior to well actually when the virus
first came into the city are now
returning because oddly enough the
places they skate to are now more
dangerous than in Hong Kong and as
they're coming back a lot of them are
actually bringing the virus back with
them
and and so we're starting to see a spike
before this week the highest infection
day that Hong Kong had during the first
two months of this was was ten
infections and one day now the highest
that we've seen in the last week was 48
so this is really the first spike that
we're seeing and so Hong Kong is
returning back to a state of alertness
to a state of caution and more and more
people are holed up at home is it
possible in mainland China that because
of this redefinition that you spoke
about where if someone tests positive
but they're not showing symptoms that is
not reported as a case that seems
significant to me does it is that part
of the explanation for why new reports
have gone nearly two to zero
III don't know if that's the if that's
the answer to it but I do actually think
that even with and remember these are
these are folks that are tested so the
data that we have is that as these folks
have been tested the tests have come
back positive that have not been added
to the official number of infections
because they're asymptomatic but they
have still gone through the process that
is part of China's containment strategy
which has worked extraordinary
extraordinarily well which is first of
all lots and lots of people have been
tested and then once if there is a
positive test returned regardless of
whether or not is symptomatic or
asymptomatic regardless of whether or
not they added to official numbers what
happens next is that they are
quarantined they're isolated and contact
tracing happens contact tracing is a key
key key action and so they go and figure
out where this person has been moving
where they've been who they've been in
contact with and all those folks that
they've been in contact with close
contact with they get tested and if they
are come back with a with a positive
test and they're also isolated and they
go through the process again so China
has not been testing people finding that
the asymptomatic and then just releasing
them and letting them go home that's
that's not the case and you know I think
to that point - Gary what you mentioned
about this traits testing and being able
to figure out who people have been in
contact with to figure out who may also
have been infected
you know when you look at what's
happening in other parts of the world
you hear you know in the United States
where where Chris and I are based right
now you were hearing that people who are
experiencing symptoms of symptoms cannot
get tested you know how does China's
ability to test so many people affect
the way that they can respond to this
and control this virus it really matters
without the significant testing and
without the contact tracing that comes
afterwards I don't think there's a way
that China could have contained it the
way that they did the same thing here in
Hong Kong we didn't have both of those
in as as as minimum requirements in a
health system Hong Kong could not have
contained it and this is actually the
reason why South Korea is the only other
country besides China that has managed
to flatten the curve is because they
aggressively tested I think by far the
highest per capita testing anywhere in
the world as far as we know right now
and they aggressively did contact
tracing and because of that even though
South Korea had this huge spike and we
thought that it was going to get out of
hand they were able to suppress it
control it and now they're in a much
much better place well one thing you
mentioned earlier that I'd love to talk
about too is on SARS and the impact that
going through that in 2002 and 2003 for
China other countries in Asia and Hong
Kong you know what what effect that
having on everyone's a preparedness in
that part of the world or the coded 19
outbreak it was significant I think the
institutional and social memory of SARS
mask matters a heck of a lot when you
look at how China Hong Kong South Korea
Singapore Thailand Japan a lot of these
countries in Asia have dealt with Cova
19 let me use Hong Kong as an example
because it's the one that I know the
most intimately but a lot of what I'm
about to say actually does apply to
those other areas of Asia so for context
SARS November 2002 to July 2003 very
very similar coronavirus to took over 19
I think there's about an 80% similarity
to those two viruses the global infected
number was a little over eight thousand
seven hundred and seventy four deaths so
my percentage
deadlier then Cova 19 is but far less
infectious than Cova 19 is now here's
why it impacted Hong Kong so much and
why the memory is so deep and actually
tells you a lot about Hong Kong's
reaction to Coba 19th all the 8,000
affected 22% were here in the city of
seven and a half million and 40%
actually 39 percent of the deaths 299
people died in Hong Kong 39 percent of
the global deaths happened in Hong Kong
and and SARS does not start in Hong Kong
it was imported into Hong Kong from
southern China and so SARS again deep
deep memory but it was a massive turning
point in the Hong Kong health care
system and also the social practices of
the city and let me let me walk through
some of that that impact because you can
actually still see it even before Cova
19 you see it every day the healthcare
system I was able to really very quickly
ramp up in capacity because of of
preparation post SARS
so after SARS Hong Kong healthcare
authorities started preparing for
greater capacity especially for
infectious diseases there were new
health alert systems warnings and
treatment protocols put in place I can
tell you that a lot of folks that were
here the for SARS will tell you that in
Hong Kong hospitals before SARS it was
actually rare to see even medical
professionals wear face masks and now
surgical masks are ubiquitous not only
in hospitals but across the entire city
Anytime Anywhere it seems especially
right now new channels of communication
and data and information exchange or
opened up with mainland Chinese
authorities and technology was
implemented including now a
supercomputer that actually does contact
tracing in Hong Kong you could trace the
existence of the supercomputer and this
contact tracing ability back to changes
that happen post SARS on this social
side there was also a huge change the
first thing I have to talk about is of
course of course masks now I know that
there is still not consensus everywhere
in the world about whether or not masks
actually helped in this situation I know
the World Health Organization as well as
governments like the US as well
Singapore say that only medical
personnel as well as people who are
actually sick and showing symptoms need
to be wearing masks in Hong Kong
everyone wears masks and the government
even though they flip-flopped a little
bit in this Epicurean this epidemic the
general the guidance says that everyone
should be wearing masks that started in
source 90% of Hong Kongers during SARS
wore masks and that habit actually has
actually stayed with Hong Kong worse and
so generally speaking even outside of
the pandemic when people are sick and
coughing you'll see them wear masks out
in public on top of that there was it
became systemic or I should say systemic
controls for hygiene and social and
public spaces so be visit Hong Kong
again before all of this happened you
will have noticed that public spaces are
constantly being disinfected one good
example that everyone notices is that
when you go into an elevator and public
spaces and buildings they will either
have one of two things potentially both
they'll either have a sign that tells
you how often the elevator buttons are
disinfected or there will be a plastic
piece of sticky plastic like that that's
plastic sheet over the buttons so there
are it's effectively becomes a flat
surface when you eat out Hong Kong is
obviously famous for its dim sum and one
of the most famous things about Hong
Kong dim sum are the dim sum carts which
are also a very popular in New York
Chinatown as an example those dim sum
carts they pretty much went away after
SARS and so most in some restaurants
you'll go to an Hong Kong now the vast
majority of them you have to order off
of the menu you don't have public carts
going around because of hygiene issues
and most nice Chinese restaurants in
Hong Kong now you will get when you sit
down two pairs of chopsticks per person
and those two pairs of chopsticks at
different colored because one is used to
grab food from the center of the table
to your plate and the other one is for
you to take the food and put it in your
mouth and honestly they're hand
sanitizers and hand washing notices
literally everywhere and this is just
part of the social behavior after SARS
safety protocols and offices everyone
knows how to shut down an office and
control traffic really well
most major offices have
temperature check machines at the very
least available and then of course
social distancing people understand
social distancing is important and so
the moment there was fear of what was
happening across the border naturally
people started social distancing
activities and self-quarantine became
pretty pretty normal so those are all
the social things as well as the health
system things that kind of change and
because of that Hong Kong was able to
react really really fast not just the
government not just the health
authorities but the people of Hong Kong
and I think that's the most important
part is that the entire city that the
community reacted and went into this
mode where you wore masks you washed
your hands you carried hand sanitizer
you stopped going to public places but
I'm curious then you know I think a lot
of people who are listening at home and
figuring out well how how can we apply
some of those things here and from where
you sit and when you see what's going on
in other parts of the world where maybe
people are struggling to make some of
these these changes you know what are
some of the specific things you think
folks can adapt in their own cultures in
their own countries I think
communication is a huge deal if you talk
to local Hong Kongers they will likely
apply that the communication from the
Hong Kong government has not been
top-notch but thankfully there have been
other authorities and certainly even
just person-to-person communication has
been pretty strong a lot of corporates
have done an incredible job in Hong Kong
in communicating very transparently with
their employees and insurance companies
have also been making available all
sorts of webinars and the materials and
made it actually quite easy for people
to understand how to get tested where to
get tested who to get tested and so that
communication I think has centralized to
some degree the messaging in a city like
Hong Kong everyone generally believes
the same thing and what they believe is
generally true of course there's still
misinformation issues as there are
everywhere but I think possibly also
because the SARS because over the course
of the 17 years a lot of the
misinformation has now been vetted
everyone knows what is true so there is
already sort of an internal radar or at
least alarm bell for things that
seem to be wrong so so I think
communication is really important from
government from corporates anywhere in
the world and I think if there is a
recommendation for health systems
I know getting tests is really difficult
one of the the things that has made
testing in China and Hong Kong currently
so effective is that there is
point-of-care testing it still really
doesn't exist or at least doesn't exist
in volume in the US and so they have to
save these tests and only a certain
number of people can get tested the
triage system then becomes overflowing
whereas here generally speaking everyone
can get tested and then of course the
contact tracing everyone knows that if
somebody that you've been in contact
with test positive you're gonna be
called in by the hospital authorities
and you're going to be tested and and
then if you're positive everyone you've
been in contact with for the last two
weeks will also be called in and people
don't really see it as as an annoyance
it's just what needs to be done and I
think because of that again the
containment has been effective great and
we have a question from Chris here yeah
Gary it actually builds on the point you
just made like people are puzzled online
how is it that China avoided the
explosion of cases in big cities like
Beijing Shanghai where people were
coming there from Wuhan how on earth did
some of those cases not explode was it
just down to really diligent contact
tracing I think it was a combination of
things first of all the shutdown of
Hubei Province certainly helped and then
the major cities actually went into
isolation and Quarantine as well
remember it was Chinese New Year so
offices were there was no one working
that week and so everyone just went home
and generally speaking in most major
cities they locked their doors and they
didn't leave now China is very prepared
for this because the technology stack in
China including consumer side services
make it really easy to lock your doors
and get everything delivered to you this
is infrastructure and this is a consumer
behavior that is already ingrained in
especially in major cities across China
so people just went home there was also
a stigma issue which is unfortunate for
people from Hebei and especially from
Wuhan
but there are plenty of stories in the
other major Chinese cities where anyone
coming from Hubei or with any connection
to hunt were ostracized during those
early days especially after the Wuhan
lockdown and and so folks that might
have been in fact carrying the virus
because they were from the epicenter
they were either South quarantine or
they were forcibly quarantine because no
one was going to spend time with them
anyway so I think for a lot of those
reasons some of them social some of them
systemic they they made it so that that
there was much less copy
person-to-person contact especially
after the authorities admitted that
human human transmission was possible
hospitals here in New York there are
warnings that they're about to get
overwhelmed what can we learn from what
happened in Wuhan like some of the
scenes from there were horrifying but
there were amazing stories as well what
should we learn from what happened there
well it started off horrifying
so in the early days when post lockdown
all the stories coming out at Wuhan and
we had we had journalists that were
there right before the lockdown they got
out about three hours before the
lockdown happened and we had people that
ended up having to be quarantine because
they were stuck in Hubei as well as a
lot of citizen journalists that were
documenting what was going on and those
images like you said Chris were
horrifying there were videos of showing
people literally laying on the ground
some were just so sick they couldn't
move others had already died and they
were just covered with plastic sheets
there are nurses and doctors that were
just crying in front of the camera
begging for help and so I think it's
important to understand that China's
health care system did not just
immediately become effective and
certainly not a new Han there was not
that much information people didn't know
what they were dealing with certainly
the the authorities were trying to help
I think at that moment but again the
information flow was not that free and
during lockdown people were screaming
off of their balconies because they they
couldn't they couldn't get food they
they couldn't even go to the hospital
because the public transportation
systems got locked down and remember
this is not who Han is not as not a city
like New York where most of New York is
walkable if you for people who don't
have cars and many many of the Wuhan
residents don't have cars if the buses
are locked down then they might have to
walk three four hours to get to a
hospital maybe not that long but they
have to walk a long way to get to a
hospital and so a lot of people were
just stuck at home and they were unable
to initially get any diagnosis or any
healthcare and so it was a disaster
but then the capacity actually ramped up
the triage system became extremely
effective I think most people have heard
now that there were two massive
hospitals with thousands of beds of
capacity that were built within ten days
and this is this is true they were they
came out of nowhere they're literally
just parking lots or flat ground and to
major housing hospital units were built
up to be clear also those were the
triage units for for those who have very
mild symptoms but that's really
important being able to get people with
mild symptoms out of the major hospital
systems so that they're not taking up
the resources of nurses and doctors
they're not taking up the diagnostic
equipment for the second confirmation
tests and also especially they're not
taking up isolation wards and
ventilators and so the moment people
started being moved out their mouth
symptoms the ones that were going to
survive and they just really needed to
be separate from family and have some
antiviral medication once they removed
out into these new hospitals the main
hospitals in Wuhan and across Liu Bei
could deal with the primary patients
especially those that are critical of
the overall test of population and do
their best to try and save them and make
sure that they are not they're not
highly infectious at the same time I
think that the health authorities in
China especially the nurses and the
doctors did a very good job of also
protecting themselves so there have been
far fewer by percentage infections and
deaths of medical staff and there were
dreams ours I mean to respond that
effectively took a kind of top-down
drive plus a willingness of a lot of
people to risk their own well-being in a
way for their perception of what they
had to do for the public good
I mean you you're well aware of that
cultural differences between
in China Hong Kong and the West deep how
do you rape the chances of say the u.s.
responding effectively should things
really explode here as they seem like
they may be about to in the health care
system side I have every confidence that
the US health care system is going to be
able to respond well I have many many
friends who are medical professionals in
the United States and they are raising
their hands and volunteering and going
to hospitals to see where they can help
so I full trust in the system and the
people that man those systems I'll have
a fair capacity in the United States is
also significantly greater doctors per
capita then in China and because of the
fact that also our health care system is
not just relying on hospitals but their
primary care physician scattered all
over the country as long as the testing
capacity and testing kits are available
across the country general practitioners
can actually administer those and it
certainly sounds like more and more Mets
med tech startups in the US are now
trying to create these home kits so that
people can start testing at home that
will help a lot my hope is certainly
that the the citizens of the US that
people are going to take this very very
seriously and realize that doesn't
matter that you may not feel sick it
doesn't matter that you think you are
young and you're not that you're not
prone to catching this virus so that
you're not in that you shouldn't you may
not be fearful of dire consequences and
death take it seriously and stay home
and don't go to public spaces and don't
be a carrier because we now know that
asymptomatic folks can be carriers and
there is a possibility that you can be
infectious as an asymptomatic
asymptomatic carrier so yeah on the
cultural side I think I don't think it's
really cultural I would say that it's
because of the impact of SARS it's
because of the social memory of SARS
that has meant people are a little bit
more selfless and I've just said okay I
will stay home because I might have come
in contact yeah weird Lisa seems of
is it some kind of vaccine it sort of
just prepped the system for people to be
ready
yeah social I see an amazing back to you
Whitney okay great thanks so much Chris
I mean and so I think it's interesting
to Gary to hear you talk about some of
the reactions and roles in whoo-hah and
some of the stories that you've heard
especially running with the South China
Morning Post and running a news
organization in in this out during this
outbreak you know what are some of the
first what does that like to run a news
organization to report during this
outbreak well running a news
organization and in a moment like
they're so close to the initial
epicenter and where the outbreak started
is complicated we were lucky we're very
very lucky that most of our senior
editors and certainly the most senior
editors are editor in chief our mass
head leadership they were all
journalists and there were reporters
during SARS so there's a lot of pattern
recognition and on uShip which meant the
moment that we got the first sort of the
first stories coming out of China
starting on December 30th people already
raising their hands in the newsroom
saying hey we got a report about this
like if it's going to be the next SAR
since a very there's a high likelihood
that this is it and we did send people
to one early on in January like I said
we also had reporters there right before
the lockdown after the lockdown we were
lucky enough to pull all of them out of
Wuhan
but we actually did change very quickly
the way that we report partially to make
sure we got the story right to dig
deeper in the places that we we knew we
had to dig deeper but also to protect
our journalists and employees so one of
the things that we did do and maybe
other news organizations would disagree
with our decision was was I think in
late January or early February even in
Hong Kong we said to our journalists you
are not to go into hospital so no more
in hospital reporting because they were
it was we knew that it was highly
infectious we were worried that they
were gonna become you know points of
spread and we just wanted to protect our
employees and our company so we did that
we also had a business continuity plan
which meant that at the drop of a dime
we could shut down the entire office and
still operate this Global News business
some of the most interesting stories
would call
is actually how technology has played a
huge role in China during this epidemic
because it frankly has changed the way
that Diagnostics work it changed the way
that containment work
it certainly has has changed the way
that consumer life works and of course
there's been a lot of instances of
really interesting censorship but also
more interestingly how the Chinese
netizens have fought that censorship and
reacted to that censorship and I do
think that there's quite a lot of
lasting impacts that are likely to
happen because of technology deployment
during this time and so I think in
talking about those some of those
lasting impacts now that you as a
country are sort of emerging from this
and coming on into a different stage
with this outbreak what are some of the
of the changes you're seeing to daily
life both as society and maybe things
that you're hearing that individuals are
experiencing as a result of this yeah I
think probably the two most interesting
changes actually I should say three the
first one is is on education now schools
have been shut down across China for
quite some time now and again this might
be I feel a little bit a stereotypical
or a caricature of China but education
is extremely important to the country
and extremely important to citizens and
we're actually just about to come up to
the national exams which say students
work 18 years for and so online
education very very quickly moved online
and part of that move online was that
courses had to be and classes had to be
reported which means that now there's
this huge repository of recorded classes
that means potential democratization of
educational material and significantly
lowered costs to get this type of
coursework from the top tier schools
whether it's high schools and
universities or primary schools to the
entire country now whether or not China
China activates on that we're still not
sure but the potential is there the
second major shift is really on
distributed workforce the idea of
working remotely it office work remotely
is not much of a concept in China and
across most of Asia certainly far less
than in the United States and I'm from
the US tech industry so it was pretty
normal it's pretty known on the US tech
industry even before this and China much
less so but because of the lockdowns not
only in Hubei but across China this has
become much more normal and people are
kind of falling into a different rhythm
of work and most importantly this has
given rise to a whole new set of
teleconferencing companies in China
because most of the teleconferencing
companies that we know of in the West
whether it's the Cisco Systems Google
Hangouts zoom that everyone uses
bluejeans
slack video they're not available in
China they don't work in China there is
this mirror internet in China
behind the Great Firewall and so there's
a whole new set of teleconferencing
systems that were used but we're not
really commonplace certainly not for
distributed workforce and now suddenly
over the last few months there are so be
interesting to see how those companies
and those services develop and whether
or not the workplace changes in China
and then finally the third thing that is
really interesting is that there was a
huge internet response to this
censorship issue in China over the
course of the last two months it
especially exploded after this
whistleblower dr. Lee died on February
7th all over the Chinese internet
hashtags like we want freedom of speech
national hero dr. Lee nice things like
that just exploded everywhere and there
have been and actually that the Chinese
government has had to respond I think
for observers a lot of observers believe
that China Chinese government's change a
narrative about dr. Lee was largely
driven by this reaction from the from
its citizens across the internet they
have been extremely creative examples
how people getting around censorship I
think China is quite famous for using
emojis to get around tech censorship I
think most people also know that the
primary messaging app that a Chinese
Internet users use called WeChat it is
heavily censored it's not just text that
censored images and censored really
effectively individual conversations
censored and so when there are specific
articles or specific posts that are
about what's happening with the virus
that people want to share and the
government thinks that it is detrimental
to whatever they will censor and OB
completely and and I'm very effectively
removed but this time around Chinese
citizens used emojis again they
translated these these posts into
ancient Chinese texts that that the the
censoring machines couldn't pick up yet
they actually translated one version of
this post to into tokens elvish language
I don't even know the name of that
language to translate into that and the
AI couldn't pick it up and then finally
I think one of my favorite versions of
this was they used the Star Wars intro
the you know that's the the angle text
scrolling it became a video and they had
the entire post but what's going on in
wuhan in that format and that went all
over the internet so I do think that
there is going to be an increased call
academics now are speaking up about
freedom of speech so there's gonna be
this increased volume of Medicine's
calling for freedom speech will be very
very interesting to watch how the
authorities in China deal with that
right and Chris you have a question yeah
it sort of picks up on that about the
you know the the stories that could come
out of this I mean there are definitely
optimistic stories that people are
feeling that you know this could lead to
more free speech of a certain kind in in
China certain things you can't suppress
maybe in the in the u.s. it might lead
to the government taking scientific
predictions more seriously not clear
that's happening yet and there's and
there's hope that this whole thing
because it's a common enemy for the
world will actually bring the world
together in some ways but I'm curious
how you think about this like President
Trump has started to referring to this
as the Chinese virus I'm curious how
that's being received in China and and
how people are feeling on this issue as
it do you think it's increased sympathy
for other countries or
actually dialed up animosity well it's
certainly not being received well across
China I think one one thing that is
still really under covered is is the the
intensity of rising nationalism at the
grassroots level across China over the
last several years and they're very
protective of the country and their
people in their history and president
Trump's comments and the fact that and
so much of the US government is now
referring to this as the Chinese virus
is not received well my fear of course
is that even prior to the the virus the
us-china conflict was escalating beyond
anything that I think most of us as
observers want to see trade tech
military ideology and now we can add
information conflict and and health
conflict health health tech conflict
especially to the list of course the
hope is that that these heightened
tensions will actually dissipate and
that the two countries can actually at
this moment in time choose to go down
one of two paths either one that further
damages the relationship or one that
actually shows what the possibilities
are of the two largest economies in the
world the two most powerful countries in
the world actually cooperate and you
know this week Thursday is the g20
conversations that are going to happen
remotely it'll be interesting to see how
US and China actually coordinate
cooperate how they communicate during
those those talks I think people want to
know how how you think this will play
out you've got you've got a very special
seat there you know looking at all parts
of the world in it what's your what's
your take on how this plays out I just
really want to be an optimist Chris but
I think that everything we see
especially the data it shows that it is
going to get far worse that before it
gets better and I'm very fearful for
what's going on in the United States
it's because of the amount of data we
have across all these different
countries you can layer very clearly
layer countries and the way that the
pandemic has been spreading on top of
one another and we know that the u.s. is
a week and a half maybe two weeks behind
Italy and we know what's happening in
what happened in Italy and what's going
on in Spain and the u.s. is catching up
on that spike and it's gonna come much
faster and it's gonna be much higher
than I think most people originally
believed or hope for so it will get
worse so the hope is that it's again
this is gonna be the optimistic side of
me that the nations will come together
that those in charge
our governments will make the drastic
necessary moves and we will be able to
come out on the other side faster than
it looks right now remember when when
China when to shut down on January 23rd
there were only 830 confirmed cases and
even if those numbers are not exactly
accurate it's nowhere near the confirmed
cases that we have in the US right now
that we see in the US so that that is
something to be very very concerned
about at 830 they shut down and even
after the shutdown two weeks later the
cases had grown to 35,000 two weeks
after that it was at at 75,000 so at
this point it is late in the US but we
know that it can still be fixed and I
think most most experts that we talked
to believe that it can be fixed with
with fast and decisive action
you know people struggle with
understanding the power of exponential
growth and a number consume smallish
today but if you believe the science
yeah
yet you you you have to act carried okay
I hope somehow you will convey to
whoever you can convey that regardless
of what some people might say in
government or elsewhere there are there
are millions there are tens of millions
there are probably hundreds of millions
of people in the US on both right and
left who are amazed by what China what
happened in China you know yes missteps
early on whatever but they're amazed I
mean it's it's eve really you know both
the Chinese government the Hong Kong
government several Asian governments
Singapore South Korea have shown a
astonishingly wise and disciplined
action against this thing and and we're
grateful like we we feel there's much we
can learn from you and so the people
most people want this to be a time of
bringing the world together I believe
that this may be the optimistic part of
me believing it but I believe in it it's
partly what these conversations are for
to try and make those kinds of
connections so we want to keep in touch
you've got an amazing seat there and I
have loved listening to every word you
said today here it's just I've learned
so much from you so thank you for that
it was a great conversation thank you
for your insight and thank you to our
whole online audience I mean this is a
journey every you know every day we're
learning something new and just in case
anyone out there is feeling a little bit
powerless and afraid or you know at the
situation I mean the one thing that
everyone can do right now I think is we
can reach out to people we can know we
can encourage each of us to be our best
selves in in this moment like I really
think it's so what the was gonna need
when people are angry and fearful we can
turn into nasty people and but when
we're when we realize how much we need
each other and are willing to just reach
out and and share stories of hope and
and share what we're feeling and shares
possibilities we can we can really
impact each other and I see so many
incredible instances of that from around
the world whether it's Italians singing
to each other joyfully from each other's
balconies or these sort of tales of
heroism that some of our health workers
are have been engaged in all around the
world there's gonna need to be a lot
more of that
but honestly every single person the
Blair part in how they are online
what they share how they react so I
don't want to be overly embarrassing
Kumbaya but I kind of think we need that
spirit right now a little bit we need
each other and Ted's gonna try and play
that role a bit so if you hate that
maybe you don't need to be here but I
hope I hope you don't hate that I hope
you like that and will be part of it
Whitney it's a fun coasting caused in
these sense to the rest of the amazing
Ted team who are in there everyone in
our individual homes they're sort of
racing around trying to make this stuff
work technically we're learning a bit
each day I hope thanks so much for being
part of this thank you everyone thank
you we'll see you all back here tomorrow
[Music]